Cuáles son las relaciones de Paraguay
con sus vecinos regionales bueno por
ejemplo con Brasil y Argentina sus
vecinos fronterizos uno de ellos las
relaciones están muy marcadas por las
energías hidroeléctricas siendo Paraguay
la nación con mayor producción de
hidroelectricidad per cápita a nivel
global con la llegada por ejemplo del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva a
la presidenta a la presidencia de Brasil
Se comprometió a respetar el Lula los
derechos de Paraguay en la mega
hidroeléctrica binacional y taipú sobre
el limítrofe río Paraná Paraguay utiliza
apenas el 22% de esta energía y el resto
aspira a venderla o a revenderla a
Brasil a un precio mínimo Asunción tiene
otra central con Argentina la yaireta
con la que también se reparte el 50% la
energía generada en la actualidad está
en curso también un proyecto de
construcción un poco polémico en parte
por los medioambientalistas y se del
corredor bioceánico del Gran Chaco un
megaproyecto como decimos para conectar
la costa del Pacífico de chile con la
costa atlántica que de Brasil y
atravesaría Argentina Brasil Chile y
principalmente Paraguay el presidente
saliente Rosa abdo fue uno de los
principales impulsores dado que Paraguay
como hemos comentado es el cuarto
exportador de soya y así también
pretende evitar pasar por el canal de
Panamá para hacer estas exportaciones
también es uno de los fundadores desde
su llegada ahora exactamente Marina lo
que te quería preguntar es que es uno de
los fundadores como decíamos no del
mercosur Entonces le pregunto Cuál es el
peso de Paraguay dentro de esta
organización en la que hay pesos pesados
de la región no como Argentina o Brasil
exactamente como dices Paraguay es uno
de los fundadores del mercosur y desde
su llegada al poder recientemente Lula
prometió también fortalecer este acuerdo
algo con lo que está de acuerdo Paraguay
y los candidatos también lo han
resaltado durante sus campañas
precisamente el candidato que va
marcando y liderando las encuestas Peña
está muy a favor de una integración
mayor con el mercosur aboga por un
Paraguay que esté firme en este
compromiso de profundizar en las
integraciones de mercosur como bloque y
también de cara al exterior de cara al
mundo también por ejemplo está a favor
de una mayor relación con la Unión
Europea también en términos económicos
Rosa y marina precisamente no los
términos económicos dentro del mercosur
Pues ahora con Santiago Peña vamos a ver
cómo avanza esta relación con Taiwán no
recordemos que Paraguay es el único país
de hecho de Sudamérica que tiene
relaciones diplomáticas con Taiwán vamos
a ver Cómo afecta todo esto al eventual
y futuro pacto entre el mercosur y China
pero pasemos ahora a otra cuestión y es
la del narcotráfico Y es que Paraguay
estuvo en el centro de la actualidad
internacional cuando en la fiscal
Marcelo pechi fue asesinado aquí en
Colombia en el Caribe colombiano durante
su luna de miel un fiscal conocido por
su trabajo en la lucha contra el lavado
de dinero contra el narcotráfico contra
la corrupción Así es rosa precisamente
Paraguay por esta particularidad
geográfica que tiene ha sido
históricamente una de las grandes rutas
del narcotráfico de estupefacientes a
través de sus fronteras Paraguay es el
principal productor de marihuana de la
región y ahora también según algunos
analistas apuntan a la cocaización del
país con un aumento de laboratorios
clandestinos en la zona del bajo Chaco
pero es que además desde la década de
los 2000 comenzaron a entrar al país
bandas internacionales precisamente a
través de Brasil y cuyas disputas
territoriales están socavando la
seguridad nacional y también están
atentando con estas personas entes
judiciales o investigadores que ejercen
una presión sobre estas bandas como fue
el caso pues del fiscal